[موسيقى]
البدايه من اخر تداعيات الزلزال الذي ضرب
تركيا وسوريا قبل 13 يوما حيث لا تزال فرق
الانغلاق لانقاذ في تركيا تخرج ناجينا من
تحت الانقاذ من بينهم شخصان في ولايتها
طاي وفيما يتجاوز عدد القتلى اربعين الفا
قدرت السلطات عدد الوحدات السكنيه
المتضرره باكثر من مليون وحده
من انطاكيا معنا من هناك مراسل الجزيره
المعتز بالله حسن معتز ماذا عن هذه
الاخبار الساره بتواصل وجود ناجينا حتى
الان وبعد عن القرار بان ربما يكون يوم
الغد هو اخر يوم للبحث عن ناجين
صحيح عبد القادر بالنظر الى عدد المناطق
التي تحدث عنها الرئيس التركي قبل ثلاثه
او اربعه ايام وقال وقتها ان هناك 19000
مبنى هذه المباني تم الانتهاء من اكثر من
ثلاثه ارباعها
موضوع تحديد انتهاء عمليات البحث هو له
علاقه بما اذا تم الانتهاء من هذه من هذا
العدد ام لا وبالتالي ما ورد على صفحه
التلفزيون الرسمي التركي هو يشير الى
احتمال ان تتم انهاء هذه الاعمال غدا على
الارض ما زال هناك عمليات انتشال جثث قبل
قليل من هذا المكان كان هناك انتشال لجثث
في هذا الموقع نرى ان
اليات الاليات الكبيره ما زالت تعمل وهي
في المقابل ايضا تقوم بهد المباني
التيله للسقوط وذلك في محاوله لانهاء
الخطر الموجود عبر هذه البيوت عمليه الهد
وازاله الالقاب هي مستمره منذ اليوم الاول
للزلزال نحن نرى هنا ان هناك سياره
للاتصالات تم وضعها من اجل تقويه الشبكه
في هذا المكان ايضا هناك كما نشاهد
الاليات تعمل على فتح الطرقات وازاله
الابنيه المهدمه قبل قليل في هذا المكان
هنا كان هناك ايضا سحب للسيارات المدمره
والموجوده في هذه الاماكن كل ذلك هو جزء
من العمل على محاوله فتح الطرقات في مدينه
هاتاي هذه المدينه المنكوبه التي تدمر
كثير كثير من ابنيتها وبالتالي هناك
محاوله من اجل فتح شرايين هذه الشرايين
هنا من اجل ازاله الانقاض بشكل كبير وايضا
من اجل محاوله الوصول الى المناطق من اجل
ازاله انقاضها وتحديدا الكتل الكبيره في
مكان قريب منها ومن هنا ما ذكرته ما ذكرته
عن موضوع انقاذ اشخاص على قيد الحياه
وبالتالي
تقدير موضوع انهاء عمليات البحث هو بيد
السلطات الرسميه الى اليوم نحن سمعنا عن
خروج ناجين وفي هذا الموقع
راينا اخراج جثث من هذا المكان وبالتالي
التقدير للسلطات الرسميه فيما اذا كان
سيتم انهاء عمليه البحث ام لا لان الرئيس
التركي كانت تحدث وقال ان هذه العمليات لن
تقف الى اخراج كل مواطن حي من تحت الانقاض
المعتز بالله حسن من انطاكيا شكرا جزيلا
لك